foreign
just a moment but first from the 8 news
now investigators a teen girl locked up
in squalor and it turns out she could
have been rescued sooner thanks for
joining us I'm Denise Valdez I'm Brian
Loftis Vanessa Murphy uncovering details
in his very disturbing case she's here
now with the story Denise and Brian
police say they found the girl trapped
in a room in horrifying conditions but
what also stands out about this report
child protective services seemingly had
the chance to intervene and help the
teen at least eight times
this is the north Las Vegas home where
police say they found the teen locked in
a bedroom with no food or water an
officer describes only a box spring and
a bed frame and a bucket more than half
full in place of a restroom the alleged
victim who had turned 18 a month ago
according to this report telling an
officer she felt like a prisoner and
this had been going on for a year three
people were taken into custody for false
imprisonment and child abuse Addie
Gonzalez described as the mother Maria
pasadin described as the grandmother and
Daniel omesgua whose relationship to the
girl we don't yet know the arrest report
States Child Protective Services advised
there were eight previous
unsubstantiated information reports
alleging abuse and neglect but the
agency reporting upon investigation
quote there was not enough cooperation
or evidence to pursue and quote finally
on November 4th police say the teen was
moved from the home that's after a
neighbor called for help saying the teen
was using a ladder to get back into our
second floor room after she had been
asking for food and water at a
neighboring home and claiming her
parents had locked her in her bedroom
and did not feed her or let her use the
bathroom
I reached out to Clark County asking for
a statement from Child Protective
Services since again it appears the
Child Welfare agency had multiple
chances to step in here and help this
teen a spokesman said they're looking
into it and will get back to me tomorrow
and by the way records show the three
defendants are no longer in jail